[musique]
Mohamed Aminjad, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct
exceptionnellement. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous représenter succintement ?
Euh je suis l'ambassadeur d'Iran et je
suis présent ici pour expéliquer à votre
audience le point de vue de la du
gouvernement iranien en ce qui concerne
l'agression illégale et légitime des
États-Unis et de l'Israël contre mon
pays et mon peuple.
Merci d'être venu en exclusivité chez
nous pour vos premières déclarations.
On parle des sujets qui fâchent tout de
suite. Façon il y a que ça à mon avis.
Est-ce que vous vous préparez vous faire
expulser par la France ?
Avant de de m'exprimer sur la question
précisément, je voudrais vous annoncer
vous expliquer que oh nous pour le deuxè
la deuxième fois on était en train de de
négocier avec les États-Unis
parce qu'ils étaient soucieux de
concernant notre programme nucléaire.
Euh tout le monde sait que au mois de
juin 2025 quand on avait passé 5 tours
de négociation de jours avant de 6e
jour, l'Israël nous a attaqué et puis
après tout de suite les États-Unis ont
fait la même chose en demandant une
capitulation
mais à la fin de 12 jours, ils nous ont
demandé non et monsieur Trump a demandé
non on veut on veut pas attaquer et
Israël doit rentrer chez lui et tout ça.
Donc il y ait eu un arrêt et puis après
on a recommencé, on avait perdu beaucoup
de
euh de commandant, des hommes
politiques, des gens ordinaires, des
gens innocents pendant les 12 jours. Euh
mais on avait on était si vous voulez
bien, on ne voulait pas vraiment
continuer et alimenter l'hostilité.
C'est pourquoi on a dit une fois
l'invasion et l'agression est arrêtée
par les Israéliens, nous allons donner
notre dernier cours et puis après on va
s'arrêter et ce qu'on a fait on avait
promis. Cette fois-ci, on avait
commencé, il y a eu deux tours de
négociation à Ouan, à Genève. On aurait
dû avoir les 3è tour à Vienne pour
aspect sur les aspects techniques si
vous voulez pour discuter sur les
aspects techniques.
Mais cette fois-ci aussi c'est le samedi
28 février dans une guerre
sans déclaration
et sans non déclarer si vous voulez
parce que
ils ont même pas prévenu Emmanuel
Macron.
ce qu'ils ont dit, voilà que ce que les
Français disent mais
c'est important que soudainement
attaquer un pays dans le
tôt le matin, le premier jour de
l'ouverture de l'administration,
ils ont attaqué beaucoup de places et
dans les premiers la maison du guide
suprême, celui qui avait prétendait les
médias si vous voulez bien qu'il habite
dans les bquers à 40 étages au-dessous
de la de de la terre et puis que pas
accès à lui tout ça mais tandis que il a
été tombé martyre avec son épouse,
sa fille, sa belle fille, trois de ses
petits enfants et une famille en tout
cas lui quelqu
il était sur sa terrasse
comment
il était à l'extérieur sur sa terrasse
non vraiment on ne sait pas.
Normalement, à cette heure-ci, il doit
être parce que le mois de Ramadan, il
doit être dans sa chambre en en se
reposant ou bien dans une dans un milieu
familial si vous voulez bien. Mais en
tout cas, c'est le mensonge mensonge
mensonge. Et puis depuis le samedi, nous
nous avons malgré le la guerre en fait
l'invasion de du mois de juin, dès le
première heure, nos nos
armées ont commencé à riposter. Donc
jusqu'aujourd'hui, on est dans le droit
naturel d'autodéfense. Donc le peuple
iranien se défendre maintenant.
Il reste maintenant votre question.
Euh
pour nous, on est diplomate,
on travaille que pour la paix.
Et s'il y a quelqu'un ou une partie qui
a déclenché la guerre à tout le monde, y
compris à l'Iran, il faut s'adresser à
lui ou à eux pour dire que voilà inf, il
y a la règle internationale, il y a le
droit international, il y a l'ordre basé
sur le droit international que tout le
monde est obligé de respecter, y compris
surtout
ceux qui sont le garant de la paix de la
sécurité de
du monde. Donc une fois cette règle est
est brisée, donc il faut condamner à
celui qui a brisé pas le la l'agresser.
Vous
vous préparez vous faire expulser ?
Non, ce n'est pas un diplomate est
toujours prêt à quitter son poste. Il y
a une une durée normale et après ça,
vous comprenez pourquoi je vous pose
cette question ? Je vous en prie.
On a dit que vous aviez attaqué une base
française, que vous êtes à un état
terroriste, que vous respectez rien du
tout. C'est c'est quand même une petite
chanson qu'on voit à chaque fois quand
il y a des diplomates qui seront
expulsés. Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre à nos journalistes, nos
diplomates, nos gouvernements du fait
que vous respectez rien, vous êtes un
état terroriste, vous massacrez votre
votre peuple, que vous tenez le pouvoir
depuis 40 ans d'une main de fer et que
il y a pas de liberté chez vous.
Euh
la base française en premier. Oui,
regardez euh nous nous n'avons pas
visé la base de quel pays que ce soit et
surtout les pays avec qui nous n'avons
pas et qui nous nous n'ont pas agressé.
Euh la France y est compris. Mais nous
avons dès le début mais avant avancé
même officiellement dans une lettre à au
secrétaire général des Nations Unies
qu'une fois on est agressé les intérêts
et les bases militaires où les
agressions sont préparées seront visées
par nous.
Et c'est dans ce cadre-là qu'on avait
visé les bases américaines dont la
mission et contre l'Iran, était toujours
contre l'Iran. Maintenant, vous voyez
euh une campagne médiatique, une
campagne de manipulation, de
noircissement,
c'est
Je peux vous arrêter monsieur
l'ambassadeur ?
J'ai demandé à ma communauté de vérifier
les chiffres de mort de la répression du
gouvernement iranien. Je leur ai demandé
d'enquiéter sur 30000 morts, 60000
morts. Bon, Donald Trump nous a dit
30000 morts. 30000 morts, ça fait
beaucoup.
J'ai ils m'ont fait remonter des photos
de morg avec quand même des des je
dirais pas des centaines de cadavres
mais plus de 60
dans des sacs mortuaires. Euh qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça ? Oui.
Euh comme je vous ai dit, pour avoir une
agression brutale comme telle, il faut y
avoir les prétextes. Il faut que que
soitdisant la l'opinion publique ou les
médias plutôt
soit prêt. Donc on avait monté des
mensonges. Nous nous avions un problème,
ce problème économique.
Le secrétaire de trésor des États-Unis a
annoncé que la politique de président en
mettant et en augmentant la pression sur
l'Iran afin de d'encourager
la le peuple iranien sorte en
protestation en réussie. Ça veut dire
qu'ils étaient en train de de préparer
l'opinion publique. Les aussi bien les
Américains mais les Israéliens ont dit
que voilà les agents de Mossad sont
inérents à côté des protestants. la
protestation quand il a commencé, il a
eu une nature complètement et tout à
fait purement économique parce qu'il y a
eu change de devises qui ont été
augmenté et puis quelques euh quelques
dizaines de de de de de commerçants de
bazar de grand bazar de terrain sont
sortis pour dire que voilà, on ne peut
pas vraiment faire la business parce que
l'autochange et nous ne pouvons pas
supporter. le gouvernement l'a entendu
et puis a pris des mesures nécessaires.
Euh beaucoup de euh de réunions, y
compris avec le président de la
République lui-même euh ont tenu et nous
avons dit "Non, on va entendu, on va
faire les choses". Mais
tant de de nuit dans de nuit,
on avait plus de dizaines hein.
Comment
on a vu des vidéos, il y avait du monde
quand même dans la rue hein ? Beaucoup
non ? Bah non, non, non. C'était au
premier au début c'était comme ça mais
après ils ont commencé dans beaucoup de
villes dans le pays avec le les
manipulations que je vous avais dit.
Mais mais pour nous
entendre les revendications légitimes
économiques des citoyens, c'est quelque
chose comme une bénédiction parce que
nous pouvons vraiment nous rectifier,
nous pouvons revoir nos politiques et
puis réessayer augmenter notre effort
pour répondre et satisfaire ces
revendications. Mais il y a eu dans deux
nuits dans deux nuits il y a eu des des
émétiers qui sont entrés dans la dans le
dégâts et puis avec les armes et il y en
a des photos, ils n'ont pas montré ce
qui est normal, on le comprend bien mais
la dans ces deux nuits combien on a
perdu maintenant comme vous dites.
Le président de la République luême
lui-même est intervenu. Il a demandé de
publier les noms avec le numéro
d'identité nationale.
C'est ainsi que nous avions 3117
noms avec carte d'identité nationale, ça
veut dire avec l'adresse toute tout
compris.
Nous avons dit c'est cela
parmi eux il y a eu plus de 500
policiers
qui ont trouvé morts
600 mutiers et les autres les gens les
protestants ordinaires ou bien les
façons si vous voulez et ils ont perdu
leur vie mais la brutalité de de de de
dans une ville
des deux côtés
des deux bien sûr côté du côté
manifestant et du côté police.
Oui. Oui. 5
que j'ai j'ai entendu dire que vous vous
tiriez sur la foule à la mitraillette.
Non, ce n'est pas vrai. C'est pas c'est
impossible ça. Comment on peut le faire
? Et quand on a donné 37
noms,
beaucoup on on prétendu voilà il y en a
15000 on a dit OK
présentez les noms.
Avant de changer de sujet dire aussi que
le gouvernement iranien faisait payer
les enterrements.
Non. Pourquoi on doit faire payer les
enterrements ? il y a les mor
cimetière où il y a le frais qu'il faut
payer. Je ne sais vraiment pas combien
le prix. J'ai même enterré mes mes
proches, ma mère tout ça et puis
demander quelque chose d'extra
c'est impossible. C'est incroyable même
ajouter à la au deuil des familles un en
charge supplémentaire. Ce n'est pas dans
la
voyez dans le comportement des Iraniens
de
le cimetière appartient aux
municipalités
même municipalités ne peuvent pas le
faire et n'ont pas fait mais il y a eu
toujours des accusations. Voilà, ils ont
demandé pour chaque tir, ils ont demandé
combien d'argent pour chaque Ce n'est
pas vrai. C'est c'est tout mensonge.
Passons à la guerre économique.
à ce que vous appelez votre défense.
On a vu le Bah, Dubaï, un peu l'Arabie
Saoudite si je me trompe pas, des
infrastructures pétrolières, des
plateformes pétrolières se faire
toucher, pas encore des installations de
dessalinisation d'eau.
Pourquoi cibler ça ? et ensuite le D3
d'Ormouse.
Ouai. Nous nous avons annoncé que
les pays riverin, les pays voisins sont
nos frères. On n'avait aucun intérêt ni
vol aucune volonté de nuir nos voisins.
Donc on se trouve toujours dans un
sentiment amical à l'envers des pays
avec lesquels nous avons beaucoup de
points communs religiaux, culturels,
historiqu et même familial parce qu'il y
a des Iraniens qui vivent dans le côté
de dans l'autre côté de de Golf Heric.
Mais nous avions dit que les bases
américaines, tous les opérations
militaire sauvage contre notre peuple,
contre notre contre notre école. Vous
avez vu à Minob 171 enfants de de
l'école primaire ont on ont ont péri ont
perdu euh
juste à côté de cette école, il y avait
pas une base militaire.
Pas du tout, pas du tout. Non, non. Dans
le passé, on disait dans le passé, il y
a eu un clube appartenant à l'armée,
mais un club, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
? relation avec une école, une grande
école avec
250 à peu près sur les frapp
et tout ça s'agissant s'agissant les les
pays de de la région, on avait dit les
bases américaines dans la région, les
intérêts américains dans la région pour
pour nous les cibles euh les cibles
légitimes et nous ne manquerons pas
d'attaquer ces cibles. comme les navires
américains dans la région. Ils n'ont
rien à faire dans la région. Ils sont
leur présence était et reste toujours
une un élément de déstabilisation
de créer la peur et de division discorde
entre les pays voisins. Mais cette
fois-ci, c'est l'Iran qui a été attaqué.
C'est l'Iran qui a perdu son guide
suprême, ses commandants et ses
installations infrastructures
hospitalières civil hospitalière
les les routes, les écoles, les
commissariats de police, le police
diplomatique erant et puis combien
d'écoles et
ont été bombardées. Donc nous ne pouvons
pas baisser le bras jusqu'à la fin de de
choses. Donc
vous êtes déjà allé à Dubaï ? Oui, bien
sûr, bien sûr. J'avais visité le Dil.
Bien sûr.
La palme. La palme. Il y a pas de base
militaire là-bas.
Non, non,
vous avez bombardé là-bas. Comme je vous
ai dit, les bases et les intérêts
américains où qu'il se trouvent dans la
région jusqu'à ce que nous puissions le
faire sont les targets euh cibles euh
légitimes pour les Iraniens, pour notre
armée iranien. Et puis nous sommes un
pays indépendant. Il pensait que dès le
premier heure, avec la disparition
éventuelle du guide suprême, le pays va
euh imploser. Ce n'est pas le cas.
On va voir ça après.
Revenons, revenons à la stratégie
militaire.
Comme vous surveillez les marchés des
matières premières et du baril de
pétrole et du gaz, le fait d'avoir le D3
d'ormous bloqué, on va dire constipé,
le fait d'avoir des infrastructures
produisant de l'énergie, le fait de plus
pouvoir exporter cette énergie que les
stocks dans les pays producteurs
arrivent au maximum, donc ils vont
arrêter leur leur leur extraction.
Vous vous anticipez quoi sur les marchés
? Ça fait partie de votre stratégie de
guerre économique, c'est-à-dire priver
les États européens, priver la Chine de
ses rentrées énergétiques ou c'est parce
que c'était des objectifs légitimes et
vous avez pas pensé plus loin ? J'en
doute.
Ouais, je vous dis, vous voyez, depuis
47 ans que la République islamique est
là, nous étions parmi les premiers et le
plus grand garantisseur
de la calme et stabilité dans cette
région.
C'est pas ce qui est dit. On dit que
vous êtes un état terroriste, que vous
non, je parle je parle sur le des tr
d'ormoise et la le on va je suis
d'accord en deux points. On dit aussi
que vous financez le esbola le Has, les
outils que vos proxy foutent le bordel
un peu partout bombardent tout le monde.
Revenez sur le D3 d'ormous et ensuite on
fait les proxis.
Ouais.
Donc s'agissant de la question d'ormous,
c'est un des trè
très serré
où nous avons le plus nous sommes le
plus grand riverin si vous voulez et
l'intérêt de de l'Iran n'est pas
perturbé la
la circulation libre et aisée des des
navires de pétrole et toutes sortes de
choses. que nous avions fait dans le
passé et nous avons montré même dans les
pires moments quand il y a eu la guerre
de 8 ans de guerre imposé par
les autres à l'Iran avec Saddam Hussein.
Nous nous avons garanti la sécurité
là-bas malgré que nous avons perdu notre
avion civil avec près de 300 passagers
par le navire américain à l'époque qui
dont le capitaine a été euh promu très
avec fanfare aux États-Unis. Donc nous
on est un pays responsable. Nous nous
n'avons pas visé ni l'Europe, ni la
Chine, ni n'importe quel pays. C'est la
tension qui existe là-bas qui a créé
cette atmosphère. Il faut s'adresser à
celui qui a qui nous a attaqué, à celui
qui est venu. Nous ne sommes pas allés
au bord des États-Unis avec armada tout
ça, tout nuir et bombarder un les
États-Unis. Ce sont eux qui sont venus.
Sans eux, c'est le paradis et comme un
dirigeant de la région disait que ça
sera l'Europe de futur l'Europe. Ben ça
c'est vrai. Les potentialités, les euh
toutes les ressources humaines aussi
bien que matérielles se trouvent ici. Et
notre intérêt est de garantir la
stabilité, la paix là et le
développement donner encore une fois une
opportunité pour toutes les peuples
nation de la région pour s'épanir. Mais
ce sont eux qu'ils ne veulent pas et
chaque fois ils viennent avec accusation
quelconque euh et comme vous vous venez
de parler avec les
euh proxy tout ça. Non, dans notre monde
il n'y a pas de proxy. Nous ne
connaissons pas. Ce sont des, si vous me
permettez, ce sont des expressions qui
n'appartiennent pas à nous dans notre
culture et dans notre région. Ce sont
nos amis. Non, Hamas, c'est un groupe
palestinien. Vous voyez, nous nous
soutenons leur cause. Leur cause est
très légitime. Il ils combattent
maintenant combien de décennies
maintenant ? près de 90 ans, il
combattent pour se faire libérer de
l'occupation israélienne. Donc je ne
sais pas si on peut trouver vraiment
quelqu'un avec une une fidélité à à la
liberté, aux valeurs humaines qui peut
accepter qu'un peuple soit bafoué et
opprimé et privé de ces droits qui ont
été connus par la communauté
internationale par les résolutions des
Nations Unies.
Ils sont là un groupe sunni. Nous nous
soutenons leur cause c'est tout. En ce
qui concerne le Hamas, il y a la
proximité religieuse et amicale entre
nous mais ce n'est pas dire que qu'ils
agissent
sous le notre ordre ou notre nom, c'est
une insulte. Il ils sont là est un parti
politique, une partie de la l'atmosphère
politique de Liban et il doit agir dans
le cadre de ces droits national et nous
n'avons pas même dans le 10 jours guerre
le bol n'a pas participé dans la la
défense iranienne contre Israël. Donc
voyez si
revenons revenons aux frappes à
l'armement à la stratégie militaire.
On a vu des petits drones à 20000 €
20000 dollars se balader, taper un peu
partout dans la région. On a vu des
missiles et là on a vu des missiles
hypersoniques qui portent le nom d'une
ville iranienne qui s'est fait massacrer
pendant la guerre Iran Irak. Comment il
s'appelle ? Vous dites ? Donc ça c'est
un missile hypersonique 15000 km/h euh
qui met 12 minutes à toucher Israël qui
a une portée de 2000 km avec euh euh
tête à fragmentation pour maximiser la
surface de destruction.
C'est parce que vous avez plus de
missile ? C'est parce que vous voulez
montrer plus les muscles ou c'est pour
un avertissement pour dire nous allons
utiliser ce type de missile sur des
infrastructures
euh vitale tel que la désalinisation de
l'eau, les raffineries de grande
ampleur, les plateformes pétrolières ou
par exemple des portesavions.
Non euh nous sans notre missile,
nous aurions fini dans la guerre de 12
jours.
C'est la seule et la principale
euh le principal moyen de se défendre.
C'est la première chose. 2è chose le
quand vous avez fait allusion à 20000
dollars de de drone. Drone c'est une
industrie iranienne pour nous défendre.
Nous n'avons pas utilisé nulle part,
sauf deux fois quand notre territoire,
pas la première fois, mais très
ouvertement pour la première fois, notre
consulat a été visé par les Israéliens,
notre consulat en Syrie à Damas. Donc
nous avons utilisé pour la réposte.
C'était la 2è et première et 2è quand il
y a eu un massacre sur le territoire
iranien d'un invité officiel de notre
président de la République actuelle
Ismaël Hanier le dirigeant Hamas et
Israël l'a tué. On a euh et puis il y a
eu on a on avait on on s'était on avait
un retenu mais après euh avec des
invasion ultérieur, on avait utilisé
pour la 2uxème fois. Donc vous voyez ce
ne sont pas les choses qui partaient ici
et là et dans le marché tout ça. Non, on
est un gouvernement et une nation
responsable. On ne veut pas
des des des des tensions partout. Et
d'ailleurs, on n' pas ni intérêt ni le
moyen. celui qui a le moyen, un jour en
Afghanistan, l'autre en Irak, l'autre
jour en Syrie, en Libye, mais partout au
Venezuela, il faut aller vraiment
s'adresser à eux et accuser celui qui
est accusable, pas l'Iran qui est un
pays responsable et puis avec la
structure très
On a proposé à l'ambassade d'Israël de
venir. Ils ont notre numéro de
téléphone, on leur réitère notre
invitation. On a proposé à l'ambassade
américaine aussi de venir discuter.
Revenons à nos moutons. Vous avez frappé
Israël. Il y a eu neuf un peu plus de
neuf morts si les souvenirs sont bons.
C'est des morts civils parce que vos
missiles sont pas précis parce que vous
avez pas le GPS ou parce que vous avez
vous avez un GPS chinois. C'était des
cibles militaires, c'était pas des
cibles militaires, c'est une erreur,
c'est pas une erreur ?
Jusqu'aujourd'hui,
nous nous avons perdu plus de 3000
civils et il y a eu des blessés, plus de
7000 blessés en Iran.
l'exemple de l'école que
les médias
dans beaucoup de pays évitent de les
montrer sur la le massacre de 171
petites filles ou garçons.
Nous avons perdu tant de vous venez de
d'entendre une école vient d'être
bombardée à la ville de Casvine. Comment
? Une nouvelle école.
Une nouvelle école. Bien sûr, il y a il
y a quelques minutes, juste avant ça, on
a on a entendu ça, on nous a annoncé.
Donc par contre ni dans la guerre de 12
jours ni aujourd'hui nous nous n'avons
pas comme objectif comme euh les civils.
Non pour nous nous avons prévenu même
que voilà il faut évacuer. vaincre parce
qu'on ne veut pas viser vous les les
habitants israéliens que ça soit juif
musulman chrétiens nous ne sommes pas
dans le bon de celui qui qui massacre
qui tue en vous avez vu que 75000
ont été vraiment ce sont des gens qui
sont dans le les décavres ont été
trouvés sinon cadavres à Gaza 75000
personnes c'est ça ? Ils ont annoncé
72000 et puis le Ham avait annoncé et
puis après les autres aussi ont confirmé
ça et puis il y a un désert là-bas et ce
n'est pas une ville.
Là, on a
Et puis vous parlez de 9 personnes ou de
11 personnes, tu es bon pour chaque
dans chaque guerre, il y a des cibles
directes, mais il y a les cibles
collatérales. Mais est-ce que vraiment
votre audience ou chacun en en Occident,
ils peuvent parler de plus de 3000
civils iraniens tués de 115 171
petites filles dans une école primaire ?
Est-ce que est-ce qu'on demande on se
demande vraiment c'est le droit de
l'homme ou c'est mais je ne sais pas
quelle quelle expression et quel
comportement on peut on peut le dire
mais on est désolé dans chaque cœur il y
a toujours des effets collatérales tout
ça que nous nous n'avons pas intention
et nous en disant notre notre armée
notre force
défensive du pays n'ont pas visé
délibérément intentionnellement
et nous ne voulons même pas viser un
animal que ce soit mais un homme un être
vivant c'est encore plus grave. Là il y
a la France, l'Allemagne, l'Angleterre
qui se prépare à faire des frappes pour
défendre ses copains, ses alliés, ses
amis, ses partenaires dans la région.
Est-ce que vous avez peur de ça ?
C'est contre de ce qu'ils ont dit. En
tout cas, en ce qui concerne la France,
hier le président de la République l'a
confirmé. qu'ils ne sont pas dans la
dans la partie de l'invasion, qu'ils ne
veulent pas le faire, mais euh
vous considérez ça comme de la
coolligérance.
Non, vous voyez, je dis mais il y a
toujours une nuance dans les prises de
position, il faut la comprendre. La
France ne veulent pas ajouter encore une
douleur à la à la nation iranienne. Bon,
c'est là, je ne sais pas ça, il faut
leur demander la demander à à ell mais
en ce qui nous concer nous ne croyons
pas que nous nous ne considérons pas
autre pays que les États-Unis et
l'Israël comme notre objectif militaire
dans un droit légitime d'autodéfense.
autres pays que de ces deux pays ne sont
pas considérés comme l'ennemi.
Maintenant, s'ils veulent si un pays pas
pas ces trois veulent vraiment venir
frapper les écoles iraniennes. Donc à ce
moment-là, on verra ce qui va croire
frapper s'ils veulent frapper vos
installations de militaire pour éviter
que les leurs alliés, leurs partenaires,
leurs amis de la région se fassent
toucher par vos missiles, comment vous
allez évaluer ça ? Oui, je je ne parle
pas sur les hypothèses.
Cette fameuse cette fameuse défense
de neutralisation préventive. Oui, mais
mais la guerre aussi a été déclarée dans
une mais tout a été planifié par les
Américains. Il n'y a pas eu préventure
d'Iran, même devant dans le Congrès. Euh
y compris les officiels
américains, ils ont dit que l'Iran
n'était pas n'est pas une un danger ou
un une menace imminente. Voilà. et et
puis ils ont créé d'une expression pour
justifier, ils ont changé le ministère
de défense au ministère de la guerre
tout. Vous voyez, c'est c'est une
histoire vraiment imaginaire et bien
connue pour tout le monde. Je je crois
pas que les armes de destruction
massive, on se rappelle bien en France
avec le discours de Dominique de
Villepin.
Votre votre leader religieux Romenaï qui
s'est fait euh bomber avec toute sa
famille. Bien sûr,
il avait mis il y a 36 ans, reprenez-moi
en terme de date, il avait émis il y a
36 ans 36 ans une fato comme quoi l'Iran
devait pas avoir la bombe.
Bien sûr.
Bon, le fait qu'il a été
maintenant c'est la preuve, vous voyez
le résultat aujourd'hui.
Le fait qu'il ait été, vous êtes
signataire du traité de non
prolifération nucléaire.
Le fait qu'il ait été liquidé,
assassiné, tué, appelé ça, bon, qu'il
soit parti au paradis
ou qu'on ait un peu aidé,
est-ce que ça va accélérer ?
le fait que vous alliez sortir de traité
de non prolifération, est-ce que d'ici
10 jours vous allez faire un test
nucléaire ?
Ce n'est pas ce n'est pas évident. Vous
voyez euh les Américains nous ont dit au
monde que nous avons ératiqué la menace
nucléaire, nous avons
euh éradiqué les
ah neutraliser toutes et nous avons
bombardé tout. Mais après 8 mois, ils
sont venus pour euh maintenant contrer
sur notre capacité nucléaire
militaire. Ce n'est pas le cas.
Nous maintenant l'opinion publique
mondiale comprend mieux que l'Iran était
un pays quand il parlait, il parlait de
la justice et il n'y avait pas eu une
une tromperie, une une des paroles qui
veut qui veut cacher, qui veut c'est le
résultat. Donc nous disons sans parole
nous coûte
une demi action. Ça veut dire que dans
un action, nous avons montré notre euh
notre fidélité, notre droiture dans ce
que nous pensons, nous croyons. Je me
souviens dans les interview, dans
l'interview précédente qu'on que vous
avez posé la même question.
Ma ma réponse était la même que nous euh
nous n'avons pas nous ne considérons pas
l'arme nucléaire comme une arme à être à
pouvoir être utilisé et puis dans notre
stratégie défensive l'art nucléaire n'a
aucun place n'aura pas aucune place
c'est la réalité des choses maintenant
pour l'avenir
on va on va voir avec l'évolution des
choses
Qu'est-ce que vous entendez pour
l'avenir ? Vous allez voir l'évolution ?
Je dis peut-être on aura un changement
sur nos moyens de défensive, mais vous
voyez euh nous avons passé nos euh si
vous voulez si je me permettre de dire
le pire des scénarios parce que nous
avons été euh et notre peuple a été
humilié deux fois par des bombardements
aveugles des Israéliens et des
Américains. Nous avons perdu notre guide
suprême. Nous avons perdu nos
commandants très chers nos commandants
qui ont fait qui faisait qui ont fait la
guerre pendant 8 ans de guerre et puis
qui ont fait contre Daesh dans la région
qui était une menace contre toute la
région. Nous avons perdu des des
innocents, des civils. Nous avons perdu
beaucoup de dégâts matériels. C'était de
la richesse là. Les acquis du peuple
iranien nous avons perdu. Donc euh pour
l'avenir, il faut que nous essayions
mais toujours nous ne sortirons pas de
de traité de non prolifération. Par
contre, il faut demander quel pays est
hors de cette non signataire de cette
euh traité et qui qui a des armes
nucléaires dans notre région. Je parle
dans notre religion parce que le pays
nucléaires officiellement annoncé, ils
ont leur business, leur machin si vous
voulez, mais Israël c'est un pays qui
qui est hors de de traité, qui a des
armes nucléaires. rapidement. Euh euh
bon, l'arme nucléaire pour vous, ça sert
pas à grand-chose parce que si vous
neutralisez l'intégralité des
productions énergétiques de la région,
plus si vous mettez un deuxième avis euh
avec les les la désalinisation, euh ça
va paralyser totalement l'énergie
mondiale. Les dommages collatérales de
ce type de frappe sont beaucoup plus
importantes en terme de de pouvoir de
nuisance plus clair. On
aucun on a aucunement cette intention
ce qui est en train de se passer là.
Non, ce n'est pas voyez,
vous avez pris vous avez vu le prix du
baril de pétrole ?
Oui, bien sûr. Bien, il y a quand
vous avez vu la tête de l'industrie
allemande ?
Oui. Vous voyez quand il y a eu une
attaque contre l'Irak, il y a eu la même
chose. Quand il y a une crise sur la la
scène internationale, il y a
l'augmentation du prix. Ce sont des
marchés qui agissent dans le premiers
rang. Mais quand vous parlez que euh les
installations, les infrastructures
énergétiques, tout ça, nous n'avons pas
intérêt à à bombarder tous ces toutes
ces choses.
Revenons à la France. Quand vous voyez
le Charles de Gaulle
se rapprocher euh des côtes chypriotes,
ça vous fait rigoler ? Ça vous fait pas
rigoler ? Ça vous interpelle ? Ça vous
fait peur ?
Non, ce c'est dans le je crois que c'est
dans la dans le cadre de la politique
française
et c'est
son stratégie
euh d'envoyer
euh Charles Dol à quel à tel point euh
du monde et pour le Liban, pour Israël,
pour n'importe quel euh objective. Mais
en ce qui nous concerne, nous comme je
vous ai dit, on a on a devant nous un
ennemi qui qui n'a aucun aucune logique
dans son comportement, dans ses
revendications, dans ses opérations.
Il est 19h23, si vous voulez voir un
coup, c'est possible. Il est 19h23. Je
On vous a mis un petit peu de
Non, c'est bien. C'est bien.
Euh, revenons à nos moutons.
On se retrouve avec une augmentation et
une augmentation dangereuse. Le monde se
trouve peut-être euh au bord de la trème
guerre mondiale. Est-ce que la Russie,
la Chine vous épaulent et de quelle
manière ? Ils vous fournissent de
l'armement, ils vous fournissent du
renseignement ou ils vous regardent ?
Euh
moi, comme un diplomate euh surtout
résidant en France dans un pays, je ne
peux pas vraiment m'exprimer euh euh
très correctement sur la situation de
des relations entre mon pays et un pays
tiers. Donc, je ne veux pas vraiment
juger sur ce point-là. Bien sûr, nous
avons des relations économiques
euh euh
avec la Chine, une amitié
qui va euh peut-être au euh des milliers
d'années, si vous voulez, quand il y a
pas eu ses noms sur l'Iran ou la Chine.
Et tout récemment, dans les années
récentes, nous avions eu une entente
politique, une coopération politique
avec la Russie. Bien sûr, on était
entré, j'ai eu l'occasion de parler que
quand euh la guerre nous a affaibli dans
tous les domaines, la guerre de vie euh
avec la Russie euh euh à ce moment-là,
l'URSS et puis la Russie, nous avions de
bons ententes de bonnes coopérations, y
compris dans le l'aspect militaire.
Pour le moment, ce qui va ce qui se
passe entre nous vraiment, c'est quelque
chose que je l'ignore, mais c'est
toujours une une un respect mutuel et
une amitié sur les intérêts communs, sur
les inquiétudes communs. sont deux pays
responsables sur la scène internationale
de membres des Nations Unies de Conseil
de sécurité qui veilleent à ce que la
stabilité et la paix dans la dans le
monde soit sauvegardé. Euh donc euh il
ils ils sont toujours une ils ont des
des des comportements responsables.
Le qui d'Orseil vous a appelé ?
Euh nous avons nous sommes en contact
avec DO
il y a combien de temps ? que
l'ambassadeur euh de France euh et euh
Jean-Noel Barou, il vous a passé un coup
de fil.
Non, normalement nous on est dans les
différentes levels si vous voulez, mais
au cas où en cas de besoin bien sûr euh
on a des discussions qu'on avait eu dans
le passé.
Il y avait une
une commémoration de la la mort de votre
leader. Elle a été annulée à Terran.
Oui. Pourquoi ? Vous avez peur des
mouvements sociaux ? Vous avez peur des
rassemblements ? Non. Vous voyez les
mouvements sociaux, ce sont des
fabrications
à l'étranger s'agissant le peuple
iranien. Aujourd'hui, c'est le 7e jour
de la maison israélo-américaine
de l'agression illégale et le peuple
iranien euh sont solidaires avec leurs
dirigeants et puis il y a toujours une
des rassemblements dans différentes
euh euh villes du pays et les euh il il
soutient il prit les combattants de la
de la du territoire iranien de la
souveraineté et
territoriale iranien. Euh non, il y a
des calculs bien sûr euh parce que on
n'est pas dans la dans une situation
normale, on est dans une situation de
guerre. Donc la vitesse des évolutions
sur le terrain est telle que qu'ils
peuvent euh annoncer. Dans ce cas-là, ce
n'était pas le gouvernement qui l'a
annoncé. Mais même si le gouvernement
annonce quelque chose mais qui après un
jour de jours il y a des des des
arguments, des évolutions qui exigent un
changement de la date d'un événement.
Bien sûr qu'on nit pas dogme sur les sur
les programmes et les les effets qu'on
a.
On parle d'un changement de régime en
Iran
poussé par les Iraniens, les occidentaux
parce que bon voilà, ils veulent ils
veulent changer le régime.
On parle aussi que les Kurdes vont être
armés. On va vous envoyer les Kurdes.
Vous allez répondre comment si les
États-Unis en plus viennent sur votre
sol.
Non, voyez le changement de soi-disant
le régime parce que on est un une
nation, un peuple avec notre système
politique mais euh comme vous dites, un
changement de régime était il y a 47 ans
à l'ord du jour. Donc nous nous avons
été l'objet d'une guerre de 8 ans avec
les dégâts humaine et matériel immense
et nous étions l'objet de tous ces
propagandes depuis 30 ans que monsieur
Netanyahou disait que l'Iran dans une
semaine de semaines un mois il aura la
bombe atomique. Vous voyez ? Donc nous
le changement de régime n'a pas changé
dans le calendrier comme monsieur Trump
lui-même a dit non la question de
l'ambassade la rupture des relations
tout ça on était attendu jusqu'à comment
ils ont passé vraiment de mauvais temps
avec la douleur mais l'Iran c'est un
pays un pays souverain qui essaie de
jouer comme un acteur responsable
Les éléments que vous voyez, vous voyez
par exemple dans un pays, il y a 100000
iraniens. Parmi 100000, il y a 50 60 70
qui sont sur les ordres des autres et
puis ils n'ont pas visité l'Iran, ils ne
connaissent pas l'Iran et les Iraniens.
comme je vous avais dit, s'il
connaissait les Iraniens, comment il
pouvait se permettre attaquer un pays et
puis euh penser que avec la
suppression du guide suprême,
aussi grande personnalité qui qui est
l'im
le
pays sera implosé ce qui n'a pas eu lieu
et chaque jour même si ils font les
mêmes choses avec les autres, l'Iran va
perdurer comme il a perduré depuis des
milliers d'années. Nous avons
expérimenté le chenguis,
mongol tout ça. Donc ils veulent le
faire. Bon s'il s'ils peuvent le faire
bon ils vont ils feront. Sinon, c'est la
nation iranienne, le peuple iranien qui
vont qui sont dans leur main le destin
du pays, qui vont continuer vraiment à
faire le changement, les réformes, tout
ce qui est nécessaire pour une vie
encore plus facile euh pour eux et pour
tout le monde qui sont concernés. avant
de passer au aux questions internet euh
parce qu'il nous reste 15 minutes parce
que vous êtes attendu juste après.
Bonjour
euh si on peut gratter 15 minutes en
plus, on est preneur. Euh je les prends
dans l'ordre euh des réponses
seront attendues. Première question.
Bonsoir monsieur Najad. Njad pardon.
Pourquoi selon vous il y a des frappes
sur les infrastructures pétrolennes
iraniennes ? Point interrogation. Y
a-t-il une puissance étrangère qui
ferait pression pour garder ses réserves
quasiment intactes pour l'interrogation
?
Ouais. Ben, je n'ai pas bien compris la
question. Si vous avez
Donc, qui c'est qui tape vos
infrastructures pétrolières ?
Qui qui c'est qui tape
chez vous les infrastructures
pétrolières ? Il y a des J'ai j'ai pas
vu de d'infrastructures pétrolière
touchées. Si, il y a
Non, ils sont pas Je vais pas entendre
de Non.
Deuxème question. Si les manifestations
en Iran n'étaient que des troubles
isolés et basés sur des problématiques
économiques, comment expliquez-vous
l'ampleur nationale du mouvement femme
vie liberté née après la mort de
Machaini
et la brutalité de la réponse des forces
de sécurité ? Euh oui, mais à au moment
de femme vie liberté aussi
euh il y a eu beaucoup de bruit. C'est
vrai, mais il y a eu une revendication
de d'une partie de la jeunesse iranienne
qui ne voulait pas vraiment euh qui
voulait une un changement, ce qui a été
fait et une oppression brutale. Bon, ce
sont des sons qui sont venus mais à ce
moment-là même personnellement,
je vivais à Terah. Il y a une petite
rappeuse qui s'est fait quand même
tabasser jusqu'à la mort. Non,
qui
une petite chanteuse qui s'est fait
tabasser. Non.
Ah, je ne sais pas de qui. Elle pas elle
a pas survécu la peau
mais mais Massa Amini, c'était une fille
avec une hobb un peu plus si vous voulez
libre pas complètement voyez
la tête nue. Donc il a eu elle a eu une
maladie.
Elle s'était à l'époque, il y a eu la
police qui avait demandé,
je ne sais pas pour quelle question euh
dans le commissariat de police, il a il
a été mort. Mais comme je vous ai
expliqué que j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
ma sœ amé comme était comme ma ma ma
fille moi-même euh à moi-même. Donc nous
nous ne voulions pas vraiment euh euh
tuer quelqu'un de nos enfants. Mais
maintenant, si on prend le prétexte
comme c récent activité économique en
protestant
protestation
civile sur l'économie, mais vous voyez,
je vous dis quelque chose,
nous avons une société très libre et
nous avons
moins libre que chez nous. Non,
il faut dire il faut vraiment
comparer les comparable. Vous voyez la
liberté chez vous a un sens. Chez nous
un autre. Vous avez une histoire, une
culture, une religion et une
constitution
selon laquelle vous êtes adapté ou que
vous soyez content ou pas. Chez nous,
nous nous avons éduqué nos enfants. Nous
nous avons donné les moyens à à
épanouissement de nos enfants. Après la
révolution, vous savez, les éléments de
de du développement euh économique et
social de l'Iran a été amélioré. Donc
les jeunesses
2è question
revendiquent et ils veulent des choses
et la la pression maximale et les
sanctions économiques, les isolements
politiques, soi-disant isolement
politique ont fait que les jeunes ne
sentent pas vraiment n'ont pas une
satisfaction. Question internet. Si le
Hamas est totalement indépendant de
l'Iran, pourquoi plusieurs responsables
iraniens revendiquent-ils publiquement
le soutien financier et militaire à ce
mouvement ? Et pourquoi Ismaël
An
oui a déclaré avoir reçu 70 millions de
dollars d'aide militaire iranienne.
Non, vous voyez, nous n'avons jamais
annoncé que nous soutenons
militairement, financièrement le Hamas.
Ce n'est pas le cas. tout le monde sait
euh celui qui finançait le Hamas et dans
des objectifs, je ne dis pas militaires,
sûrement euh euh économique et
humanitaire, je n'accuse pas n'importe
quel pays de d'aider le Hamas. Et Ismaël
Hanas, il a dit ça, il lui a il a dit
mais ce n'est pas le gouvernement
iranien qui ni accepté qui ni revendiqué
une une telle aide à à Hamas. Question
internet. Compte tenue du soutien de
certains pays d'Europe avec l'attaque
d'Israël et des Émirats arabes unis,
l'Iran va-til engager des offensives
contre ceuxci économiquement,
militairement et cetera ? Les liens
sont-ils rompus à long terme
avec qui ?
Avec Israël, les les Émirats arabes unis
et l'Europe. Certains pays d'Europe,
l'Italie, ils veulent pas venir chez
vous, hein.
Pour faire quoi ? pour vous taper.
Non, taper l'Iran.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les rapports sont
à long terme foutus ?
Non. Pourquoi ? On a on même les
relations actuelles n'ont pas été
touchées parce que les les
accompagnement sur la parole avec euh
les États-Unis, tout ça, c'est une
chose. Mais en ce qui nous concerne,
nous voulons avoir des relations fiables
euh sur les bases des euh de droits
international. avec tout le pays. Donc
l'amitié avec les autres pays, c'est la
main de l'Iran qui estendu le premier la
première. Donc je ne crois pas que cette
imagination peut peut se réaliser. En
tout cas, je ne le souhaite pas parce
que je sais qu'il y a une sagesse.
Question internet. Selon lui, quelles
sont les réelles intentions des
Américains d'un côté et israélien de
l'autre ? Ils ont dit ils vont ils vont
changer le régime que ce tr vient de
dire que même pour euh le guide le choix
du guide, il faut qu'il soit euh
impliqué, qu'il choisissent. Donc c'est
contre toutes les réglementations
internationales revendiquer euh changer
un régime euh euh nommer des présidents.
Vous voyez on on sait pas où on est en
train d'aller aller chasser un président
d'un pays dans la dans la nuit et puis
euh vous voyez les choses
sont tout à fait clair je crois pour
l'opinion publique internationale. Il il
y a une question pour nous. Est-ce que
les questions posées sur le chat de
Discord sont lues par l'équipe ? La
réponse est non parce que depuis qu'ils
ont voulu nous mettre une
authentification avec carte d'identité,
on a décidé de plus aller sur Discord.
Même s'ils ont changé d'avis, rien rien
que le fait qu'ils émettent l'hypothèse,
ça nous a vacciné. Euh question
internet,
je la prends, je la découvre avec vous.
Vous étiez passé il y a quelques temps
sur cette chaîne, perceviez-vous
l'arrivée de la guerre ? Et vous
êtes-vous fait,
êtes-vous vous fait pardon, excusez-moi,
ou êtes-vous fait surprendre pourquoi
auriez-vous anticipé une sortie de cette
guerre ?
Euh, d'abord
sur des intentions guerrières des
autres, comme je vous avais expliqué, il
y a plus de 30 ans qu'il cherchent à
préparer des prétextes, à envahir l'Iran
et à avoir Vous avez vu la la vidéo de
Wesley Clark ? Non,
de 2007,
Wesley Clark, grand général qui
dirigeait l'OTAN en Europe,
il dit, je vous raconte la vidéo rapide,
il dit euh juste après le 11 septembre
2001, je viens voir des potes au
Pentagone et je tombe sur mon aide de
camp. Il me dit "Oh, viens voir mon
général, viens voir mon général,
regarde, c'est notre notre plan
militaire, on va aller taper l'Irak et
puis seps, puis on va terminer sur
l'Iran." Et le général lui dit "Est-ce
que c'est classifié ?" L'autre lui dit
"Bah oui, c'est classifié." Alors lui il
était pu habilité donc il dit me montre
pas ça. Vous avez vu cette vidéol ?
Oui. J'ai entendu dire ça. J'ai entendu
dire ça. Donc vous dites tout. Vous
dites tout. Euh non,
je dis tout et vous dites rien. C'est
ça.
Non non, je vous Non non. Comme vous
vous dites, ça veut dire que vraiment
vous donnez vous présentez la réalité du
terrain et de ce qu'il pensait que de ce
qu'ils pensent.
Pourquoi ils veulent vous mettre à terre
si ça fait 30 ans ? Oui,
c'est pourquoi ils veulent aller vous
taper par tous les moyens ? C'est parce
que vous êtes assis sur les plus grandes
réserves de gaz de la région.
Non.
C'est parce que vous les dérangez ?
C'est parce que Ah, c'est parce que vous
avez décrété que Israël, vous allez lui
faire sa fête quoi qu'il arrive. C'est
la mort de l'État d'Israël, la mort des
du grand Satan américain.
Non, il y a il y a vous voyez, il y a la
discorde entre nous et les États-Unis.
les États-Unis n'a pas un vraiment un
une un passé très satisfaisant chez
notre peuple. Vous vous souvenez qu'à
1953,
c'est les États-Unis qui qui ont imposé
qui ont fait orchestrer euh
une un coup d'étan en renversant le
premier ministre Musader à l'époque et
en mettant la main sur le pétrole
iranien. jusqu'à là euh c'était dans la
manmise des
des anglais si vous voulez les
britanniques. Donc euh et après dans la
dans le comportement du gouvernement du
chat, son savac, son système de
sécurité, son euh [rires]
les États-Unis étaient toujours à côté
des des dictateurs dans la région. Mais
en ce qui concerne la révolution
islamique, donc c'était une volonté du
peuple que ça plaise aux États-Unis ou
pas ou à n'importe quel pays. Mais la
peuple iranien voulait prendre en main
leur destin, voulait être un pays
développé, euh indépendant, libre comme
vous savez euh République, que le choix
ne soit pas imposé par la dynastie, par
le père à enfant. Donc euh c'est normal
qu'ils ont des euh des haines. Et puis
vous savez qu'il y a le plan d'expansion
de de la mer au aux rivières qui
comprend les plans d'expansion de qui ?
euh Israël euh la Jordanie, une partie
de des Arabistes Saoudites, la Syrie,
une partie de l'Irak. Donc toutes ces
superficie qu'ils et tout récemment
l'ambassadeur des États-Unis, vous avez
entendu dire que que c'est bien qu'il
fasse qu'Israël fasse cette mission et
finisse avec. Mais pour nous, l'Iran est
euh un élément de de barrage pour eux,
c'est tout à fait normal. voir un peu de
jus de pomme. Euh euh et comme ça ça me
permet de de regarder à droite et de
vous poser une autre une autre question
en mode tranquille. Je vous en prie.
Euh je vous laisse vous servir. Ah
ouais. Bienvenue en Union européenne. On
a des bouchons piégés. Méfiez-vous, ça
en met partout.
Très bien.
Hop. Je vous pose je vous pose la
question. Comment on fait maintenant
pour avoir la paix ensemble ? Comment on
fait pour vivre sur cette terre pour
avoir la paix ? Certes, vous allez me
répondre "Bon, il faut arrêter
l'agression américanoisraélienne."
Vous allez me dire vous allez me dire
que
j'ai un avocat qui me dit
"Arrêtez de m'envoyer des messages
pendant le direct, vous serez bien
aimé." Comment on fait pour qu'on ait la
paix maintenant ? Comment on fait pour
se mettre autour de la table ? Quelle
puissance peut faire office de médiation
? Si les Américains ont peur ou les
Israéliens ont peur que vous ayez un
programme nucléaire, est-ce que la
Russie va récupérer les 400 kg d'uranium
pour faire une puissance médiatrice ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour vous
mettre autour de la table et arrêter
tout ça ? Parce que les Iraniens se font
taper, les Israéliens se font taper, les
Dubaïotes se font taper, tout le monde
se fait taper, le business va mal, le le
pétrole augmente, le gaz augmente, ça va
créer, ça va coûter 40 milliards au au
Allemands, ça va nous impacter nous, ça
va faire de la misère partout. Comment
on fait pour réconcilier tout ce petit
monde ?
Je pense la clé,
venez manger à la maison tous ensemble.
J'invite les Israéliens, j'invite les
Américains, je vous invite vous, je fais
à manger et puis on se détend. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ?
Voyez, la clé de la question de la
solution du question n'est pas dans la
main des Iraniens.
Nous, nous étions toujours
les premiers
peux vous couper
à négocier.
Je peux vous couper ? sûr.
Moi je me je me fais l'avocat du diable
et je dis voilà bon bah changement de
régime. Donald Trump il vous a dit au
départ si vous déposez les armes, on
vous garantit l'amnistie totale.
Vous comprenez pourquoi je me fais
l'avoqué du diable ?
Ouais. Oui. Oui. Bien sûr.
Ils vont vous dire "Vous démissionnez,
vous démissionnez tous et hop, c'est
terminé."
Voyez, le peuple, la nation iranienne
doit doit démissionner pour donner
la place aux Américains et puis je ne
sais pas les le peuple viendra de quelle
partie du monde
remplacer ces 90
millions habitants iraniens. Mais je
vous dis très simple, depuis 2003,
maintenant c'est plus de 23 ans, nous
étions
en négociation. En tout cas, on nous
avait demandé
donner l'assurance que vous n'avez pas
une intention
autre que civil.
On a dit OK, mais il revendiquait trop
trop. Mais pour nous, ça ne changerait
rien. Ça ne changeait rien parce que
notre intention était tout à fait claire
et évidente.
Après, on a commencé la négociation à
2000 de 2013 à 2015, on est tombé sur un
accord. On est tombé sur un accord après
la l'effacement de toutes les prétendu
revendication, tout ça par l'agence de
l'énergie atomique, l'agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique. On
a conclu un accord, un accord qui
a prévu une supervision,
une inspection
gigantesque sur toutes les installations
nucléaires iraniennes.
Et les autres ?
Les autres, ça veut dire les autres
pays.
Non, les autres cachés.
Non, il n'y a pas de cachet. Il n'y
avait pas eu de cachet. Et c'est une
c'est une technologie qui est bien
connue, qui est bien surveillé.
Donc ce n'est pas quelque chose à
cacher. S'il y a eu des cachets, c'était
les prétentions du passé qui ont été
tout blanchis.
Donc on était tombé dans un accord. Tout
le monde apparemment était satisfait.
diront a renoncé à beaucoup des
avantages de son avantage de ses
avantages mais quand même il y a eu une
un souffle si vous voulez on a eu des
ouvertures dans les coopérations
économiques. Vous savez des dizaines
peut-être des centaines de délégations
françaises, allemandes, italiennes sont
partis en Iran. Nous avons conclu des
accords et jusqu'à 2018 18 que monsieur
Trump a décidé de de déchirer cet accord
et de sortir de sacord de cet accord. Et
depuis maintenant
8 ans la guerre après 7 ans dès la
première entrée dans le 2e tour il a
commencé à se préparer à à réaliser ses
intentions néfaste ça veut dire guerrier
contre l'Iran. Donc l'Iran a montré que
c'est un peuple de dialogue de
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Je suis un homme
de parole. J'avais dit que je vous
gardais jusqu'à 19h45. Il est 19h48.
Est-ce qu'on fait 15 minutes de plus ?
Comme comme on vous a dit, j'ai une
cérémonie.
OK.
commémorative.
Je vous laisse terminer votre réponse et
je vous pose juste la dernière question.
Signature de la Vous avez terminé votre
réponse ? Oui oui oui, je vous ai dit
que l'Iran
avait prouvé
question internet.
Si l'Iran a dos au mur, est-ce qu'elle
serait prête à s'associer avec des
groupes militaires indépendants ou
terroristes dans la région ?
Je ne sais pas de quel groupe
cette personne parle ou que l'Iran soit.
Non, c'est l'Iran c'est un grand pays.
Ce n'est pas un groupe et un un petit
tr livres à conseiller à notre trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et après je vous laisse
filer.
Merci beaucoup. Non, vous voyez
aujourd'hui, je vous dis maintenant 1 an
euh que je suis tellement occupé
euh par les événements que vous
connaissez, tout le monde connaît,
surtout après la l'agression que je n'ai
pas vraiment le temps de de lire des
livres et de vous présenter des livres,
mais je suis certain par mes
compréhensions, mais aussi pour par mes
informations que fort heureusement
l'opinion publique euh française et bien
éclairé et ils connaissent maintenant de
plus en plus l'Iran, les réalités des
choses sur l'Iran et la nature pacifique
du peuple de la nation iranien.
Trois livres hein.
Trois livres.
Euh non, je crois que sur les poésie
iraniens, ils peuvent toujours compter
sur Hafè, sur Molav euh et sur euh euh
le Charnamet.
Il y a beaucoup à apprendre là-dessus
comme je j'ai présenté au premier euh
aux premières interviews ici. Ce sont
des livres qui peuvent vraiment aider à
ce que la richesse de la culture
profonde et originale iranienne et puis
la nature de de la paix de des iraniens.
Avant que vous donniez votre conseil aux
jeunes générations, je voulais vous
remercier
parce que vous avez respecté votre
parole parce que ça fait à peu près 2
ans qu'on sent le couvenir. Donc c'est
pour ça qu'on on a essayé de rentrer en
diplomatie,
c'est grâce à vous
en diplomatie, en discussion avec vous
parce que euh on fait aussi de la
géopolitique et de la géostratégie et de
l'anticipation.
Merci d'être venu en exclusivité chez
nous pour votre première déclaration.
Merci. J'écoute votre conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Chaque fois, il y a beaucoup de
changements et je suis certain qu'ici en
France aussi la jeunesse
ont une autre idée, une autre conception
de la vie et je crois par ma mon
enseignement, ma culture, ma religion
que
qu'être à côté de la justice
à côté des agressés et contre les
agresseurs.
et essayer vraiment de
de réaliser un monde différent de ce que
nous avions eu où il y a la dignité de
l'homme, la vie de l'homme qu'il soit
noir, blanc, musulman chrétien, juif,
peu importe, soit vraiment respecté et
sauvegardé et que nous n'ayons pas une
domination quelconque par un pouvoir
contre les autres et puis que les
relations humaines puissent s'établir
entre tout le monde. C'est à ce
moment-là que nous pouvons vraiment nous
être avoir la fierté d'être un homme
euh pas des des machines ou des des
choses et puis qu'on qu'on aime aux
autres ce qu'on a. Si on a des euh de
bonnes éducations, de bonnes
infrastructures
euh urbaines, de bons euh
installations euh euh dans les campagnes
autres, que cette soit que ce soit euh
généralisé dans le monde entier et à ce
moment-là, nous pouvons être vraiment
très contents. Si je vous propose une
interview avec l'ambassadeur des
États-Unis, vous et lui à côté ou
l'ambassadeur d'Israël, vous acceptez ?
Vous acceptez pas ?
On verra avec le temps.
Mohammed Aminjad, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]